aggressive on the recruiting IBM errs
you have 200 people at the company
tell us about your strategy there yeah
so okay so via inaudible Canada yeah
it's a great hit the city has a great
history of technology and there's a lot
of people working in technology but you
know like the dot-com bust was pretty
brutal here yeah so a lot telecom
company here right lots of lots of
telecom companies lots of great ship
companies you use a blackberry queue
Nexus here
yeah mixer software so and so on so
there's lots of things going on but it's
who's left of a larger companies right
so what but what we think is one of the
things that chop if I became really good
at is making what we call secondary
markets work like secondary markets is
you know every city which isn't so
everything other than Silicon Valley or
maybe New York City so how a great big
meaningful impactful company is being
made it's like it has a geographical
region that somehow realizes best is one
company that all the best people go to
and spend a couple of really exciting
part years of a career together and then
they disperse again to do many other
things and we would like to be this
company so to us the most important
thing is you want people to think of us
when they plan their careers and if they
are signing up for lots of interesting
how interesting work but are willing to
work really hard for you know really
caring and with a lot of passion and
hopefully you come to us and it turns
out there's a lot of these kind of
people around in this city but baby bird
coconuts for example between got so to
IBM and when you're an IBM it's it's
funny when you speak to someone from
from IBM you might speak to someone
who's like say 30 or so and you ask them
how's it like and they tell you well
it's great and there's really great
pension and and so you just ask why do
you care about pension you're 32 yeah
like how how did I be I'm getting your
head so much but you care about some
application it's I don't even know they
had pensions exactly so it just makes me
blush driver it's
moments of mind but somehow we managed
to get in your head and and and and and
people will just build themselves like a
fun life outside of IBM and then they go
there and so on and and and but it
doesn't it shouldn't be that way because
was a great people and they should have
company a great thing so to us it's
important like to remind people that if
if if they really care about there's
better ways to have impact so we got
like we got this news where IBM was
doing big layoffs in the city and we
were thinking well you know we really we
want to hire lots of people we want to
be a we're growing quickly it shall be
face to be extremely well right now so
why don't be send some people out to
vote this and put a recruiting booth out
and that was generally like clearly was
bit cheeky but it was well-received
because I don't know if you if you pull
ten people high-performing people about
their their careers three four five of
them to tell you oh I got I got fired
once like people just people's careers
are neverbeast like materia crisis well
yeah I think about it never perfect yeah
like I think Cheryl in a book called it
sort of quick jungle gym like that's
much more much better metaphor for what
a greener Korea looks like and you know
sometimes this isn't stuff that has to
have my book for Siemens as an
apprentice and I got one of those
letters from them saying your
performance isn't up to par and I was
like terribly shocked by that because I
fall above myself is a really good
programmer but then I realized you know
like I probably haven't slept in the
entire week because I'm playing video
games at night or in programming
probably my performs wasn't they're good
and made some changes and this this kind
of things might end up turning turning
out to be really really beneficial
things and I think that's worth
reminding people off yeah yeah like you
know the police come to shut you down
people out pretty quickly moving us away
from the property that IBM owned
broccoli Bears government-owned sidewalk
or nearby so that that that was that was
convenient